este es un modelo muy simple del átomo
el núcleo en el centro del átomo es
donde viven los protones y neutrones
pero son medio aburridos porque nada más
se quedan ahí sentados el protagonista
aquí es el electrón el electrón le toca
hacer todas las cosas interesantes cómo
moverse saltar por todos lados enlazarse
con otros átomos estas líneas punteadas
representan los niveles de energía que
puede tener un electrón dentro de un
átomo nos gusta representar estos
niveles de energía con diagramas de
niveles de energía con los diagramas de
niveles de energía podemos mostrar
cuánta energía tiene un átomo sin tener
que dibujar un átomo con un montón de
círculos alrededor supongamos que
nuestro átomo hipotético tiene un nivel
de energía de 0 de 4 v 6 cb y 7 electro
volts observa que moverse a la derecha o
izquierda en un diagrama de niveles de
energía
no significa nada técnicamente no
tenemos al eje x en los diagramas de
niveles de energía pero de todas formas
lo ponemos porque hace que el diagrama
se vea bien lo único que importa es el
cual nivel de energía se encuentra el
electrón o sea en cual escalón observa
que el electrón de este acto muy
hipotético solo puede existir en el
nivel 0 4 6 ó 7 ve los electrones no
pueden existir en medio de 2 niveles de
energía siempre tienen que estar en
alguno de los niveles pero bueno digamos
que nuestro electrón empieza en el nivel
de energía 0 v supongo que es bueno
saber que al nivel de energía más bajo
que puede tener un electrón le llamamos
estado fundamental y cómo pasan los
electrones del estado fundamental a
cualquier otro nivel bueno para que el
electrón llegue a un
de energía más alto tenemos que darle
más energía al electrón y si sabemos
cómo darle más energía le aventamos luz
y un fotón con la energía adecuada choca
contra un electrón el electrón absorbe
la energía del fotón y salta a un nivel
de energía mayor un electrón en este
estado fundamental necesita 4 electro
volts para saltar al siguiente nivel de
energía o sea que si un fotón con
energía 4 m llega y choca contra el
electrón el electrón absorbe la energía
del fotón haciendo que desaparezca y
saltando al siguiente nivel de energía
al primer nivel de energía después del
estado fundamental le llamamos el primer
estado excitado
una vez que el electrón se encuentra en
un nivel de energía mayor no se va a
quedar ahí mucho tiempo los electrones
si se les permite bajar el menor nivel
de energía posible nuestro electrón
bajará al estado fundamental liberando 4
electro volts de energía y la forma en
que los electrones liberan energía es
emitiendo un fotón
si es que después de regresar al estado
fundamental el electrón emite un fotón
de 4 electro volts aunque los electrones
no tienen que saltar los niveles de
energía uno por uno
si un electrón en el estado fundamental
absorbe un fotón de 6 electro volts el
electrón salta directamente al nivel de
energía 6 v y ya que está en un mayor
nivel de energía va a tratar de regresar
pero en este caso hay varias formas en
las que podría regresar el electrón
podría regresar al estado fundamental de
un solo salto emitiendo un fotón de 6 v
pero como el electrón empezó en el nivel
de energía de 6 v también puede bajar
primero al nivel de energía 4 m
emitiendo un fotón de 2 electro volts es
un fotón 2 v porque el electrón bajó 2
electro volts de energía y como ahora
está en el nivel de energía de 4
bajará al estado fundamental emitiendo
un fotón de 4 v así es que los
electrones a veces bajan varios niveles
en un solo salto pero a veces deciden
bajar escalón por escalón de cualquier
forma la energía del fotón siempre es
igual a la diferencia entre los niveles
de energía del electrón ahora qué pasa
si nuestro electrón está en el estado
fundamental y llega un fotón de 5
electro volts si nuestro electrón
absorbiera la energía del fotón tendría
un nivel de energía de 5 electro volts
pero este no es un nivel de energía
válido así es que el electrón no puede
absorber al fotón y el fotón solo pasará
a través del átomo recuerda que el
electrón del átomo o absorbe toda la
energía del fotón o ninguna no puede
absorber sólo una parte bueno ya es hora
de averiguar cuáles son los fotones que
este átomo hipotético puede absorber
si un electrón se encuentra en el estado
fundamental puede absorber un fotón de 4
v de 6 v o de 7 v si un electrón se
encuentra en el segundo nivel de energía
también conocido como el primer estado
excitado el electrón puede absorber un
fotón de 2 v o de 3 v y si un electrón
se encuentra en el tercer nivel de
energía o sea el segundo estado excitado
el electrón solo puede absorber un fotón
de un electro volt esos son los únicos
botones que este átomo puede absorber
fotones con 2.5 electro volts solo van a
pasar a través del átomo fotones con 5
electro volts solo pasan a través del
átomo fotones con 5.3 electro volts
pasan a través del átomo lo que esto
significa es que si encendemos una luz
que consiste en todas las longitudes de
onda posibles
y la dirigimos a través de un gas
compuesto por puros átomos como este no
todas las longitudes de onda lograrían
atravesar el gas algunas de esas ondas
serían absorbidas y dispersadas en
direcciones aleatorias lo cual se
manifestaría en forma de líneas oscuras
en el espectro de luz las longitudes de
onda faltantes o sea los niveles de
energía faltantes corresponden a la
energía de fotones que nuestros
electrones pueden absorber es como la
huella digital de un átomo y se les
llama el espectro de absorción de ese
átomo
si alguna vez observas este patrón de
líneas oscuras en exactamente la misma
posición sabrás que el gas que estás
observando está por lo menos
parcialmente compuesto por estos átomos
hipotéticos y es esto lo que les permite
a los astrónomos determinar de qué está
hecho nuestro universo aunque no podamos
acercarnos lo suficiente como para tomar
una muestra
lo único que necesitamos es recolectar
luz de alguna estrella lejana una cuásar
que brille a través de las cosas que nos
interesan y luego determinar qué
longitudes de onda o niveles de energía
son los que desaparecieron los detalles
son un poquito más complicados pero esto
es lo que les da a los astrónomos
probablemente la herramienta más útil
que tienen ahora el espectro de
absorción son todas las longitudes de
onda o niveles de energía que el átomo
absorbe cuando la luz pasa a través de
él también podrías preguntar por el
espectro de emisión el espectro de
emisión son todas las longitudes de onda
o energía que el átomo emite cuando los
electrones saltan a niveles de energía
más bajos puedes tomar todas las formas
posibles en las que un electrón baja su
nivel de energía pero vas a obtener las
mismas longitudes de onda para el patrón
de emisión que para el de absorción
así es que si en lugar de hacer pasar a
un rayo de luz a través de un gas
compuesto por sus átomos hipotéticos
digamos que pusiste en un contenedor un
gas compuesto únicamente por tus átomos
y haces que pase una corriente eléctrica
a través de él excitando sus electrones
a un mayor nivel de energía y luego
dejando que regresen a un nivel de
energía más bajo eso es lo que sucede en
las lámparas de neón o si estás en el
laboratorio eso es lo que pasa en los
tubos de descarga de gas entonces para
el espectro de emisión en lugar de ver
el espectro electromagnético completo
pero sin algunas líneas sólo vas a ver
unas cuantas líneas que corresponden a
la energía de los fotones que el átomo
está emitiendo pero creo que tengo que
ser honesta en esto a cualquier físico
que esté viendo este vídeo seguro le
están dando unos escalofríos tremendos
porque la energía que tienen los
electrones no
positiva la energía que pueden tener los
electrones siempre tiene valores
negativos y esto es porque los
electrones se enlazan con los átomos
cualquier cosa que se enlace con otra
cosa tiene la energía total negativa una
analogía es una pelota atrapada al fondo
de una zanja si la pelota no se mueve
tiene energía cinética cero y si
suponemos que el estado fundamental está
a nivel del piso a nivel h igual a cero
entonces la pelota tiene una energía
potencial gravitacional negativa y como
la pelota tiene energía total negativa
está atrapada en la zanja si alguien
pudiera darle suficiente energía como
para que tuviera energía total positiva
la pelota podría salir de la zanja y no
seguiría atrapada para hacer que nuestro
átomo hipotético sea un poco más
realista vamos a restar 10 electro volts
a cada nivel de energía
no cambian nada en realidad para que el
electrón pase del estado fundamental de
menos 10 v al primer estado excitado de
menos 6 v sigue necesitando un fotón con
4 electro volts de energía las personas
suelen confundirse con los valores
negativos
así es que ten mucho cuidado para
encontrar la energía del fotón que fue
absorbido permitido siempre tomas el
nivel de energía anterior y le restas
el nuevo nivel de energía en este caso
tomaríamos menos 6 v y le restaría mos
menos 10 v lo cual nos queda como 4 v
eso nos dice que se necesita un fotón de
4 electro volts de energía para hacer
que el electrón salte es el nivel de
energía y que el electrón emitiría un
fotón de 4 electro volts si regresará de
ese nivel de energía otra cosa que es
poco realista acerca de nuestro átomo
hipotético es que un átomo real no
tendría tres electro volts como su
máximo nivel de energía los átomos
reales tienen niveles de energía que se
aproximan y se aproximan cada vez más al
nivel de cero electro volts y qué pasa
cuando un electrón obtiene más de cero
electro volts de energía bueno pues si
un electrón tiene más de cero de energía
eso significa que tiene energía positiva
y si tiene energía positiva ya no está
enlazado al átomo tiene la libertad de
irse y se va a ir y nosotros vamos a
decir que hemos guionizado al átomo
cuando le quitamos el electrón por
ejemplo si el átomo empezó en el nivel
de energía -4
y absorbió un fotón con -7 electro volts
de energía
entonces ese electrón ahora tiene 3 m de
energía positiva así es que ya se salió
del átomo